[Musique]
le walk of fame
la venue des célébrités et ses 2500
étoiles de stars une seule étoile attire
les touristes carrelet johansson ou
leonardo dicaprio
non pas du tout
[Musique]
je ne savais absolument pas que donald
trump c'était une star à faire c'est
vraiment bizarre je croyais que c'était
le président mais c'est une sphère
c'est vraiment étrange c'est yoostar si
trump est gravé dans le marbre
c'est pour un programme de télé réalité
à succès vous êtes viré formule culte la
signature du milliardaire comme partout
aux états unis il énerve et ils
fascinent
[Musique]
je vais voter pour donner le trump à ce
que je crois qu'il donnerait sa chance à
tout le monde et je me fiche de ce que
pensent les autres qu'ils aillent se
faire [ __ ]
ils nous aiment pas pourquoi c'est une
histoire de free il est riche il ne
connaît rien à la politique tu vois ce
que je veux dire
ils s'en fichent des gens des malades
des infirmes
tu comprends il n'y a que l'argent qui
l'intéressent il pourrait appuyer sur le
bouton et boum c'est la guerre la
campagne vue d'hollywood
une histoire de stars qui s'engage
pourquoi vous êtes là vous êtes une star
je suis un acteur et un citoyen
personnellement je le soutiens mais je
ne m'exprime quand mon maître
je crois que 13 et l'intériste je crois
qu'il est très dangereux pour se tenir à
jouer les candidats utilisent les
acteurs les acteurs utilisent les
candidats des actrices rangés comme un
seul homme derrière hillary pour prendre
le pouvoir à hollywood et en finir avec
la misogynie ambiante que les femmes
soient solidaires entre elles
cette remise de prix en avant des femmes
qui sont en coulisses ce sont elles qui
permet aux autres de se retrouver devant
la caméra
je crois qu'il ya plus d'égalité hommes
femmes en iran qu'à hollywood il ya plus
de réalisatrice en héros à los angeles
la démocrate dont l'industrie du
divertissement véhicule surtout les
valeurs républicaines
j'avais été moins engagé politiquement
j'aurai une meilleure carrière je vais
gagner beaucoup plus d'argent et
j'aurais fait pas cool du tout le temps
d'une campagne électorale
plongez au coeur de la schizophrénie
politique d'hollywood
[Musique]
alors là il ya une vue assez
extraordinaire
là tu vois tu es le cinéma dit woods qui
est derrière toi là-bas
[Musique]
ans
on n'est pas arrivé à il fait une
chaleur de dengue et on doit aller tout
l'art aulas
[Musique]
eriko nenê à los angeles il en connaît
tous les secrets
ça c'est le chemin de la mecque la mer
le signe d' hollywood
ouais absolument parce que pour les gens
hollywood c'est une religion vous qui
vivait à los angeles depuis toujours
vous les voyez tous ces gens qui
viennent à hollywood pour réussir c'est
vrai les gens viennent ici avec un rêve
oui avec leurs rêves il y en a très peu
qui réussissent d'autres changent de
parcours et pour la majorité
leur rêve son visa jamais
ce coach sportif m'emmène dans un
endroit inconnu des touristes
oui le signe hollywood par là par la
voilà on est arrivé on est derrière le
signe l'envers du décor ou comment le
monde du cinéma influence les élections
présidentielles américaines
[Musique]
sept mois avant l'élection
présidentielle la campagne des primaires
bat son plein
je
[Musique]
je me rends au meeting du dernier
adversaire d'hillary clinton dans le
camp démocrate
bernie sanders
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
sa force un discours gauchiste limite
révolutionnaire
[Applaudissements]
ful je croise tim robbins acteur
oscarisé pour un film de clint eastwood
c'est un soutien de toujours du parti
démocrate
pas
ouais
monsieur robbins bonjour bonjour s'il
vous plaît une question pour canal + la
télévision française
je voudrais savoir pourquoi vous allez
voter pour bernie sanders
pourquoi je vais voter pour berne et
soleure
parce que je crois que c'est le candidat
qui devrait être à la maison blanche
je pense qu'il peut pas être donald
trump et je suis inquiet ses faiblesses
qu'il arrive je pense que bernie sanders
était un bien meilleur candidat mais
pourquoi vous êtes là vous êtes une star
pourquoi une star soutien tels bernie
sanders je suis un acteur est aussi un
citoyen personnellement je le soutiens
les jeunes avaient cru qu'en mon nom
[Applaudissements]
saunders est devenu la coqueluche des
jeunes désabusés par la politique
je rencontre un mandat une productrice
de télévision de 26 ans
[Musique]
que pensez vous du fait qu autant de
stars hollywoodiennes soutiennent bernie
sanders
je trouve que c'est génial que les
célébrités s'engage leurs fans
attendront leur voix bien pouces qui
n'entendent celle des politiques et ils
voteront pour des idées ce qui les
touche vraiment alors je trouve ça un
jour
mesdames et messieurs merci d'accueillir
sur scène des acteurs souffle en salles
françaises fischer a joué dans titanic
aux côtés de dicaprio et kate winslet
[Applaudissements]
danny glover lui et l alter ego de mel
gibson dans l'armé fatale
on ne vote pas pour une personnalité
mais pour quelqu'un qui s'est donné pour
mission de dire la vérité
[Applaudissements]
accueillir le prochain président des
états unis s'est permis sans heurts
mais ce soir la vraie star c'est lui
papy sanders 75 ans
ce déni aujourd'hui nous avons recueilli
plus de 9 millions de voix
l'eau personne ne peut prévoir l'avenir
au fil des mois
sanders est devenu le cauchemar
d'hillary clinton qui était persuadé de
remporter les primaires faciles
je suis rien madame qui viole crapuleux
la rend nerveuse je crois nous allons
gagner ici viennent pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hillary clinton elle n'a pas fait de
grand raout à los angeles son mari bill
s'est contenté d'une visite aux
fonctionnaires de l'éducation dans un
quartier de l'est de la ville
200 personnes on est vraiment loin des
stades pleins à craquer de sanders
en guest star tout de même deux monstres
sacrés du basket mondial
voici magic johnson kareem abdul jabbar
nous sommes enthousiastes parce que nous
sommes ici pour faire élire la prochaine
présidente des états unis hillary
clinton
allez on l'applaudît
accueillir william jefferson clinton
bill clinton entre en scène il pourrait
devenir le premier flirt gentleman de
l'histoire du pays
kilari est la seule personne qui peut
insuffler un changement dans ce pays
billy fait le show pendant vingt bonnes
minutes que vous devez voter pour
hillary clinton
[Musique]
bien aucun doute
[Applaudissements]
pour contrer l'engouement qui entoure
papy sanders hillary clinton a ouvert
des permanences dans toute la ville
[Musique]
comme ici dans ce centre commercial
situé au coeur de los angeles
les militants rameute les électeurs par
téléphone je m'appelle stew je suis
bénévole pour la campagne d'hillary
clinton en californie comment allez vous
super est ce que vous venez voter mardi
les bureaux de vote sont ouverts de 7h à
20h alors assurez-vous d'être à l'heure
ce jour-là une star de la télévision
fait le déplacement
kate walsh l'un des médecins de grey's
anatomy
[Musique]
merci beaucoup à tous d'être là pour
votre temps et vos efforts merci de
décrocher le téléphone avec autant
d'énergie pour encourager les gens à
aller voter
je pense que nous sommes tous conscients
du fait que c'est une élection
particulièrement importante et qu'il
faut que les électeurs de californie
soutiennent hillary clinton
ce que vous faites est difficile est
primordial merci
pensez vous que votre soutien en tant qu
a créé c'est un atout pour hillary
clinton
c'est quelqu'un mais coûte parce que
j'ai interprété le rôle d'addison dans
des séries télévisées pendant près de
dix ans c'est génial mais là on n'est
pas en train de faire ma promotion
il s'agit de notre avenir à tous cette
élection nous concerne tous c'est pour
notre pays
elle aussi est venu motiver les troupes
kathleen sibelius une femme politique de
premier plan
elle a porté avec le président obama le
système de santé pour tous l'obamacare
vous faites un reportage sur la campagne
oui c'est hollywood et la politique
parce que ces demandes sont très
imbriquées quand on mettait en oeuvre la
loi de la santé on s'est vite rendu
compte que les acteurs avait beaucoup
d'influencé et pouvait toucher
énormément de gens qui n'étaient pas
sensible à la politique en temps normal
les stars sont entendus par des gens qui
ne le prête d'habitude aucune attention
aux discours politiques
alors c'est très bien je me rends compte
que les gens ici sont très heureux
qu'une actrice d'hollywood et fait le
déplacement
c'est une manière pour moi de donner un
coup de main faire une photo un saïfi et
dire et je vous soutiens de tout coeur
qu'est ce que vous avez écrit
hilary est la candidate la plus
qualifiée pour protéger diriger et
servir notre pays ici et partout dans le
monde
que dieu bénisse il arrive merci ça m'a
fait plaisir
[Musique]
deux jours plus tard la californie doit
départager hillary clinton et bernie
sanders un vote crucial qui désignera le
candidat démocrate
[Musique]
je retrouve amanda la jeune productrice
de télévision rencontrait au meeting de
bernie sanders se dévêtissent tic vous
allez voter oui c'est ici c'est une
église c'est une église oui c'est
l'heure du vote
je suis tellement contente de faire
partie du processus démocratique
c'est comme
ça c'est pour vous insérer sa dans
l'urne électronique
oui on attend me suis ok la machine est
d'accord génial
maintenant vous pouvez partir alors
c'est bon elle a voté je me posais une
question vous ne demandez pas de pièces
d'identité sinon c'est un kirby en
californie en californie comme dans la
plupart des états en fait ça veut dire
que je peux voter si je prend le nom de
quelqu'un d'autre en fait
théoriquement si vous avez l'adresse de
cette personne c'est possible % d'heures
je suis fier de voter pour bernie le
soir même le couperet tombe pour un
mandat et les supporters de sanders et
la douche froide leur candidat est
arrivé derrière hillary clinton sa
course à la primaire démocrate s'achève
ici
je veux tous vous remercier d'avoir fait
partie de cette révolution politique
à partir d'aujourd'hui nouveau mot
d'ordre est nouvel adversaire
nous ne permettrons pas à donald trump
de devenir président des états unis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai rendez vous avec rosanna arquette
actrice mondialement connue notamment
pour son rôle dans le grand bleu
elle me reçoit dans sa propriété de
malibu beach plus de 300 m² avec vue sur
l'océan
[Musique]
rosanna arquette a soutenu bernie center
pendant toute la campagne
savez ce que c'est frustrant j'adore
dany sanders cela d'or mais maintenant
il faut non tellement difficile parce
que je souhaite qu au dernier arrivé est
ce que vous allez vous engager
personnellement pour faire élire hillary
clinton
je voterai pour ilaris même si c'est
très difficile pour moi de le dire parce
que mon âme de révolutionnaire est un
rond pour dermot ça me donne envie de
pleurer mais je crois qu'il ya un enjeu
énorme aujourd'hui dans notre pays
vraiment nous les retrouvons avec un
homme comme donald trump intérêt la
maison blanche
je crois honnêtement que c'est la fin
des états unis c'est mon sentiment c'est
à dire c'est la fin du monde
je crois qu'il est très très très
dangereux parce que je crois que c'est
un idiot et ça m'est égal de le dire
ouvertement appareils s'il devient
président il s'assurera que je ne
travaille plus mais je m'en fiche je
crois que trump est l'antéchrist
[Musique]
une centaine de poids lourds d'hollywood
eux revendiquent publiquement leur
soutien hillary clinton comme george
clooney leonardo dicaprio
eva longoria meryl streep ou beyoncé
tout le casting de the avengers y est
allé de son clip
[Musique]
sans ménagement pourquoi les acteurs
américains s'engage-t-il autant un
conseiller du parti démocrate a son idée
sur la question
selon lui pour les acteurs la politique
c'est valorisant
le but c'est de satisfaire leur égo
d'une autre façon ça leur donne plus de
profondeur que leur image de star de
cinéma
ils se sentent plus importants car ils
ne sont pas seulement un rôle dans un
film tout à coup leurs paroles a du
poids donc c'est juste de lego ce n'est
que de négoce est toujours une affaire
d'ego
ensuite ils peuvent se vanter dire
j'étais à ses côtés depuis le début je
suis intelligent je comprends la
politique
j'ai un point de vue et je sais qui est
celui qui doit être le président des
états unis puis encore son candidat est
élu il faut dire à tous ses amis avec
grande fierté
j'ai parlé au président des états unis
je les conseillers le président a suivi
mes conseils pour un acteur être en
contact direct avec le président c'est
prestigieux prestige hillary clinton l'a
bien compris et c'est en tirer profit
kim kardashian la reine des réseaux
sociaux
l'actrice jennifer aniston et le couple
en vogue justin timberlake et jessica
biel la candidate collectionne les
selphy avec les vedettes de précieux
faire valoir
mme ashton
à l'autre bout du pays donald trump se
moque dit larié de son casting
hollywoodien lui qui remplit des stades
avec les classes populaires
[Applaudissements]
hillary clinton ne fait pas de discours
elle ne fait pas de conférence de presse
et ce depuis presque trois cents jours
elle ne fait pas de grand meeting comme
les nôtres les seules personnes qui
s'enthousiasment pour elle et sa
campagne ce sont des célébrités
d'hollywood et souvent des stars plus
très fraîche
c'est sûr que côté trump les stars se
font plutôt discrète
[Musique]
pas facile de trouver des acteurs qui le
soutiennent ouvertement un seul a
accepté de me rencontrer
pas vraiment une star un ancien
mannequin qui a eu son petit succès dans
des séries télé
[Musique]
bonsoir j'ai rendez vous avec antonio
sabato manning club
ils m'attendent merci au revoir
[Musique]
il nous reçoit dans sa résidence
fin juillet devant un parterre de
républicains antonio sabato a dévoilé au
grand jour son soutien à donald fait
[Musique]
c'est la responsabilité du gouvernement
absolument notre pays a besoin de donald
trump pour que l'amérique soit de
nouveau une grande nation alors c'était
une soirée émouvante un moment très
intense et c'était génial
c'était super d'être entouré de gens qui
adorent leur pays et qu'ils sont prêts à
tout pour leur nation soit de nouveau au
sommet de sa gloire
depuis que vous soutenez donald trump
vous qui êtes un acteur et qui travaille
à hollywood
est ce que ça vous a posé des problèmes
j'ai su par ménage en par mes managers
que certains directeurs de casting ne
m'engagerai pas à cause de mon soutien
mais comme je le dis toujours et ça me
touche ça car sous leur poids
c'est injuste d'engager ou non les gens
en fonction de convictions politiques
nous vivons un moment très important
pour notre pays et les gens doivent dire
ce qu'il pense nous devons nous sentir
libres d'exprimer nos opinions et puis
ensuite nous faisons ce que nous avons à
faire c'est à dire lire un scénario et
exercer notre boulot d'acteur est ce que
vous croyez que donald kohn va être élue
je crois que donald trump serait je
crois qu'il va gagner avec une majorité
écrasante
a los angeles un homme dénonce la
pression des démocrates sur le monde du
cinéma
c'est un ancien procureur républicain
alan jackson
comment allez-vous ravi de vous
rencontrer comment allez-vous très bien
vous avez trouvé facilement oui il y a
quelques années
alan jackson a été condamné pour meurtre
un producteur de musique mythique phil
spector ce procès l'a rendu célèbre il
ya une femme de l'alcool une perte de
contrôle
phil spector dégaîne une arme explique
aujourd'hui l'ancien procureur est
devenu avocat
pourquoi est ce que c'est si compliqué
d'être républicains à los angeles
si vous êtes républicains à hollywood il
faut le cacher à son tour sans que vous
ne pouvez pas réussir à hollywood
si vous êtes ouvertement république donc
si vous êtes un jeune acteur ou
réalisateur et que vous dites on est
fort que vous êtes républicain vous être
rejetée par l'industrie de l'hybride ne
vous serez blacklisté black is texte
blacklisté absolument en tant qu'acteur
si vous avez déclaré ouvertement que
vous étiez républicain vous ne
décrocherez pas le rôle auquel vous
auriez pu prétendre
c'est une certitude d'ailleurs je
connais personnellement des scénaristes
des réalisateurs des producteurs
je ne révélerai pas leur nom bien sûr
ils sont tous républicains mais ils
doivent le dissimuler
les seules célébrités qui assument leurs
idées républicaines sont les vieux
briscards qui ne craignent plus rien
pour leur carrière
clint eastwood sylvester stallone ou
l'ancien boxeur mike tyson et bruce
willis qui va jusqu'à mettre sur sa tête
la moumoute et la casquette de treuil
[Musique]
ça c'est bruce willis maintenant on sait
vraiment ce que vous pensez
[Musique]
la californie est un fief électoral
démocrate à la dernière présidentielle
en 2012
obama récolté 59 % des voix c'est vrai
que les républicains se font plutôt
discrets à los angeles
alors quand on en croise on ne les
laisse pas passer
bonjour j'étais dans ma voiture je vous
aperçu et j'ai vu que vous souteniez
trump a oui nous le soutenons et c'est
assez rare à hollywood de trouver des
gens qui le soutiennent ouvertement
pourquoi vous êtes là aujourd'hui on
veut juste faire passer notre message
c'est que les gens voient que parmi nous
il y à des juifs des mexicains des
asiatiques des vétérans tout le monde
soutient troubles ça montre qu'on est
tous les jours j'y crois plus que la
veille
c'est pour ça que je suis là va faire
passer le mot j'adore le cou aux idées
reçues on dit qu'il est raciste
au contraire les gens de toutes les
origines milite pour lui derrière qu'il
aille se faire [ __ ]
tu parle à la caméra mais tu me regardes
pas un c'est bien ce que je pensais à
rien dans le pantalon
vous allez voter
ce pays a besoin de quelqu'un qui
comprend la valeur du dollar
un patron qui créent des emplois et qui
sait comme on gère des affaires
quelqu'un qui sait ce qui est un budget
et qui sait qu'on ne peut pas vivre au
dessus de ses moyens on a besoin de
quelqu'un qui a toutes ces notions et
qui est capable de rebâtir notre
économie rejoignez-nous pas d'enfants
pas pays n'ont pas trop tôt que dieu
nous préserve
batteur qui d'autre on va rendre sa
gloire à la ville trump a raison
l'amérique a viré trop à gauche et on ne
veut pas de ça à la maison blanche on
est sérieux c'est la dernière chance de
l'amérique vraiment que dieu vous
bénisse
il faut voter trump c'est tout personne
d'autre ne peut faire le boulot dans cet
hôtel de luxe de beverly hills se tient
chaque année une cérémonie très sélect
une remise de prix aux femmes les plus
en vue d'hollywood
actrice réalisatrice et productrice
je travaille pour canal+
[Applaudissements]
oui
à cinq mois de l'élection la campagne
est dans toutes les têtes
l'an prochain nous fêterons les 100
premiers jours de la première présidence
féminine
or oui ou alors on décernera un prix am
l ania trump peut-être d'autres lui même
viendra chercher son prix parce qu'il
excelle dans tous les domaines donc il
est certainement une femme formidable
regardez sa magnifique chevalier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est le premier tapis rouge
des femmes des âmes et encore des femmes
parmi elles rosanna arquette
vous savez nous les femmes nous sommes
l'âme de l'univers c'est vrai
ici tout le monde espère qu hillary
clinton sera élu et l'assument
les filles nine cag la theurre et
réalisatrice rallye vous rencontrez je
travaille pour canal+ au fantastique
on lui doit notamment des épisodes de la
série culte homeland
c'est une année électorale donc c'est
très important est peut-être qu'ici aux
états unis vous allez avoir pour la
première fois une femme présidente
oui c'est très excitant et cela va
changer la donne
vous personnellement est ce que vous
allez voter hillary clinton
bien sûr madame fischer je suis vanina
cambon de canal plus je réalise un
documentaire sur hollywood et la
politique
lucy fisher est une productrice de renom
la saga divergentes c'est elle une
trilogie phénomène qui a généré près de
800 millions de dollars
[Musique]
vous allez peut-être avoir la première
femme présidente hillary clinton
est ce que ça va changer les choses pour
les femmes si elle est élue je l'espère
j'espère que les droits des femmes
resteront une priorité pour elle comme
ça l'était au début de sa carrière
politique
j'espère qu'elle aura assez de temps et
d'énergie mais d'abord il faut qu'elle
soit élue et puis j'espère qu'elle aura
assez de force pour faire en sorte que
ça reste une priorité
je pense aussi qu'à force de voir des
femmes occuper de tels postes de pouvoir
les mentalités des jeunes générations
filles et garçons vont évoluer pour qui
allez vous voter si vous voulez bien le
dire bien sûr je voterai pour la
candidate démocrate
l'engouement pour la candidate démocrate
n'est pas seulement politique
elle espère que l'élection d'une femme à
la maison blanche va faire bouger les
mentalités jusqu'à hollywood on
travaille dans un milieu créatif mais
quand il n'y a pas de diversité raciale
pas de parité hommes femmes
et quand les histoires se ressemblent
trop les films qu'on propose au public
devienne lisse sans saveur toutes ces
femmes dénoncent le sexisme dans le
monde du cinéma
il n'y a pas d'égalité homme-femme que
ce soit derrière la caméra ou devant la
caméra et même à tous les niveaux et le
fait qu'il n'y a absolument aucune
parité c'est juste un terrifiant
je pense qu'il est nécessaire de mettre
un coup de projecteur sur ce problème
denise di novi est une spécialiste des
comédies populaires sens mieux bar du
pont c'est ce que l'événement de ce soir
est important pour lutter contre le
sexisme à hollywood
les statistiques sont claires pour tout
le monde
il n'y a que 4 % de femmes réalisatrices
à hollywood ces justes fiables
[Musique]
je pense que plus nous discutons des
questions concernant le manque de
diversité à hollywood
tous voulaient mettant sur la place
publique et plus les choses changeront
je pense que nous sommes aujourd'hui à
un moment clé quand j'ai commencé à
réaliser des films il ya 25 ans et à
l'époque je venais du milieu de la danse
indienne féminin j'ai été horrifié de
voir qu'il y avait aussi peu de femmes
réalisatrices et le fait que la
situation n'ait pas évolué et nous
sommes en 2016 c'est totalement
inacceptable
les femmes d'hollywood veulent profiter
de cette année électorale pour faire
changer les choses
une productrice a pris la tête du
mouvement elle a créé une association
pour défendre la cause féminine dans
l'industrie du cinéma qui a raté les y
réalise des clips pour dénoncer les
rôles dévolus aux femmes dans les films
américains
regardez cette vidéo à la hausse les
rôles stéréotypes de femmes inclut la
bombasse comment vendre un film sambath
les pousse plus j'aime que sont maryse
la mer dépourvu de toute sensualité et
sexualité les femmes au cinéma sont
perçus de cette façon depuis toujours il
y a beaucoup de femmes talentueuses à
qui on ne donne pas leur chance si on
cultive toujours le rôle de la femme en
tant qu'objet la femme sera traitée
comme un objet une étude sur les rôles
féminins a été réalisée par une
université de los angeles
les chiffres sont accablants selon les
statistiques les personnages principaux
sont des femmes dont seulement 13% des
films aux états unis
la plupart des films que nous voyons
raconte des histoires du point de vue
masculin bat mais en story si larry
clinton devient la première femme
présidente de l'histoire des états unis
pensez vous qu'elle pourrait faire
évoluer la condition féminine à
hollywood the wind et je ne sais pas si
ça changera à hollywood
mais si elle est élue et devient la
première femme présidente
cela signifie que les femmes peuvent
atteindre ce rêve le rêve est de vivre
dans une société qui n'est pas
déterminée par le sexe
en créant un film ancré l'adn d'une
culture car le film est le reflet de
notre société et vice versa de grandes
actrices soutiennent le combat de
kératine esi robin wright jessica
chastain juliette binoche jodie foster
ou encore penelope cruz tout réclament
des rôles plus importants
le
j'aimerais bien savoir ce qu'en pensent
les hommes
j'ai rendez vous avec un grand nom
d'hollywood
martin campbell réalisateur de films
testostéroné comme james bond ou zorro
depuis quelques années maintenant les
femmes à hollywood dénonce ouvertement
le sexisme au sein de l'industrie dont
le sexisme à hollywood
tous les rôles principaux de vos films
sont des rôles masculins en fait bien
sûr sauf dans beyond borders
c'était une femme c'est l'exception oui
et il ya aussi web en fait bien de
border c'est le seul mais je crois que 2
euros
nous avions une femme forte le
personnage de catherine zeta jones
oui mais catherine zeta jones avait oui
bien entendu
c'est vrai je ne fais pas ce genre de
film que ça fait de moi un coupable mais
vous avez raison on n'écrit pas de bons
rôles pour les femmes
l'industrie du cinéma est donné par les
airs
les actrices ne sont pas les seuls à
avoir du mal à s'imposer sur les
plateaux pour les réalisatrices aussi le
machisme ambiant serait un problème
patricia riggen a fait un énorme carton
au box office avec son dernier film
miracle du paradis les rôles principaux
ils sont tenus par des femmes dont une
star hollywoodienne
jennifer garner mais selon la
réalisatrice
le tournage a été un cauchemar est
magnifique
pensez vous qu'il est plus difficile
d'exercer le métier de réalisateur quand
on est une femme
quand on est réalisateur on a besoin de
l'aide d'une grosse équipe
la difficulté quand on est une femme et
que l'on manque de crédibilité c'est la
pure vérité
même à hollywood absolument à hollywood
je crois qu'il ya plus d'égalité hommes
femmes en iran qu'à hollywood
je crois qu'il ya plus de femmes
réalisatrices en iran qui si je vais
vous expliquer ce que c'est que d'être
une réalisatrice femmes
d'abord on vous engage d'accord on a
franchi le premier obstacle mais ce
n'est pas la fin de vos soucis c'est là
que la torture commence parce que
personne ne vous écoute c'est vous la
réalisatrice
c'est votre travail vous êtes le chef
d'orchestre mais personne ne vous
respecte on met en doute tout ce que
vous dites et toutes vos demandes
on essaie petit on vous ignore on ne
croit pas en voie d eau mais qui les
producteurs votre équipe tout le monde
pour moi cette discrimination montre
exactement ce que c'est que d'être une
femme réalisatrice et c'est ça le fait
d'obtenir le poste ne garantit pas le
respect de l'équipe pendant tout le
tournage je me bats chaque jour réaliser
une interview avec patricia riggen dont
le film a cartonné au box office
elle m'a raconté les difficultés qu'elle
a rencontrées en tant que femme que
réalisatrice
parce que l'équipe de tournage était
masculine
mais je sais je sais et on ne l'écoutait
que d'une oreille mais je parie que
quand vous êtes sur votre plateau de
tournage ça ne se passe pas comme ça oui
c'est vrai c'est une histoire de respect
bon tout simplement les femmes ne
reçoivent pas les mêmes égards que les
hommes c'est terrible c'est tout à fait
terrible
twilight un film de vampires devenu
culte pour la jeunesse du monde entier
[Musique]
un succès international signé catherine
hardwicke
[Musique]
la réalisatrice mme reçoit chez elle
dans sa propriété de venice l'un des
quartiers les plus branchés de los
angeles elle aussi dénoncent la
misogynie d'hollywood elle garde un
souvenir amer d'une journée de tournage
qui ne se passait pas comme elle
l'entendait qu'on avait un impératif
tourner lorsqu'il y avait des nuages
d'accord si c'était ensoleillé on ne
pouvait donc pas tourner un jour on
attendait le retour des nuages on
essayait de créer de l'ombre
c'était censé être une journée nuageuse
et c'était très frustrant
du coup je suis allé pleurer derrière un
arbre pendant une minute
quelqu'un m'a vu la répéter et tout le
monde s'est dit elle et émotive
en fait j'ai appris que le terme et
motive c'est du langage codé pour dire
femmes c'est misogyne en fait j nesteq
bien sûr mais si un homme pleure sur le
plateau de tournage
on l'applaudît car il est sensible mais
une femme qui pleure et émotive
il ya deux poids deux mesures si hillary
clinton et à lui est ce que ça va
changer la donne pour les femmes
je crois que chaque victoire comme celle
ci améliore la cause féminine chaque
femme forte qui accompli quelque chose
d'incroyable nous aide
elle donne l'exemple si elle peut le
faire moi aussi des gens me disent je
vous ai vu dans le dvd dans le making-of
de twilight j'ai vu que vous étiez
réalisatrice cela m'a inspiré et m'a
donné envie de faire des études de
cinéma
j'ai envie de réaliser mes propres films
pleins de gens m'ont dit ça c'est génial
tout ça parce qu'ils m'ont vu donner des
ordres sur un plateau
malgré un énorme succès au box office
plus de 350 millions de dollars de
recettes
elle n'a pas été rappelé pour réaliser
le deuxième opus de la saga twilight qui
est responsable de cette situation
les patrons des studios les financiers
les producteurs et bien que peut-être
tous
par exemple le patron du studio dit
qu'il veut un film de super héros qui
appelle ton pour le réaliser le week-end
personne ne se dit va confier ça à une
femme personne ne veut poser le pari ce
qu'il faudrait c'est qu'un patron de
studio ordonne son langage une femme
pour réaliser ce film met à la place ils
disent appelons martin campbell
il a réalisé des james bond il est bon
c'est un film d'action envoyez lui le
scénario
en fait ça devrait être un vrai choix
politique qu'à se tasse oui absolument
malheureusement oui malheureusement mais
il leur manque les couilles
voilà le truc c'est ça les couilles oui
je les couilles de dire qu'une femme à
réaliser ce genre de film mais du coup
vous aurez moins de travail ouais c'est
pas grave
le pouvoir serait donc entre les mains
des patrons des studios et des
producteurs ceux qui financent les films
ceux qui embauchent les réalisateurs et
les scénaristes l'un des décideurs les
plus puissants d'hollywood m'attend
robocop terminator le silence des
agneaux apocalypse now c'est lui en
quarante ans de carrière ce producteur à
porter à l'écran un nombre incalculable
de films cultes
j'ai participé à la production de 320 ou
323 film il ya eu un tiers de
chefs-d'oeuvre un tiers de films moyens
et pour le dernier tiers
on aurait mieux fait de me coller un
pistolet sur la tempe et d'appuyer sur
la gâchette avant dit tout haut je
voudrais parler avec vous de la
discrimination envers les femmes
durant toute votre carrière combien de
femmes réalisatrices avez vous engager
mon dieu j'en ai aucune idée aucune idée
woody allen n'est pas une femme milos
forman scorsese rue
oliver stone n'est pas une femme kevin
cosner non plus j'ai beau regarder les
affiches autour de moi c'est des hommes
mais ils ont du talent bien sûr
alors c'est quoi le débat n'est quand
même pas leur faire porter des jupes
c'est vraiment aux femmes d'affirmer
leur point de vue il faut qu'elle prenne
la parole
elle se fasse une place parce que sa
place les hommes veulent leur place il
n'y a pas que les femmes
et bien bonne chance les filles c'est
pas gagné
et avec trump ça serait encore pire
monsieur trump une chose que l'on
apprécie chez vous et votre franc-parler
vous avez traité les femmes que l'on
n'aimait pas de grosse [ __ ] chienne
séné ans et d'animaux écoutant à votre
avis est-ce un trait de caractère digne
d'un candidat à la présidence et comment
répondez-vous à l'accusation d'hillary
clinton qui dit que vous êtes en guerre
contre les femmes
je crois que le gros problème de ce pays
et que l'on est trop politiquement
correct on m'a reproché tellement de
choses
et franchement je n'ai pas le temps
d'être politiquement correct trump botte
en touche mais la misogynie a fini par
lui coûter cher dans sa course à la
présidence
pour les deux candidats
la californie n'est pas qu'un réservoir
de voix c'est aussi le coffre fort de
leur campagne
cet état le plus riche du pays les stars
y organise des dîners privés pour
collecter du cash comme on avril dernier
dans la villa de george clooney amis et
soutiens d'hillary clinton 30 3000 $ le
couvert en bout de table
mais pour les bonnes places à côté du
comédien ou de sa femme il fallait
débourser beaucoup beaucoup plus trois
cent cinquante trois mille dollars
dick hollywood et le distributeur de
billets de la maison blanche
absolument pour les deux partis
politiques
la californie finances la route vers la
présidence
les acteurs ont toujours été généreux
avec les candidats à la présidentielle
ici à los angeles et plus
particulièrement de woods
il est plus facile pour les candidats à
politique de réunir des gens et de
récolter beaucoup d'argent ils viennent
ici parce qu'ici il y a du cash en fait
vous êtes en train de l'expliquer que
les candidats à la présidence se servent
de la notoriété des stars d'hollywood
pour ce faire il ya ça marche dans les
deux sens aussi bien pour les candidats
que pour les stars ils en tirent tous
profit chacun y trouve son compte
le candidat a besoin de crédibilité
il a besoin d'argent d'une couverture
médiatique pour valoriser son image et
c'est exactement ce que les acteurs lui
fournissent
belair quartier ultra chic de los
angeles
[Musique]
le levée de fonds pour donald trump est
prévue dans la soirée ici à bel air les
donateurs qui participent verseront 2700
dollars rien que pour entrer au cocktail
est dix fois plus pour assister au dîner
[Musique]
donald trump est à los angeles il est en
train de faire une levée de fonds ce
soir avec des milliardaires américains
qui sont trop jump la police veut dire
qu'on est pas loin
blake faut qu'on retrouve cette maison
c'est une maison d'un particulier
extrêmement riche mais on sait
absolument pas où c'est on n'a pas
d'info donc on va essayer de trouver
donald kohn
[Musique]
avec tv bonsoir je sais qu'il ya une
levée de fonds pour donald sommes pas
loin d'ici
est ce que vous savez où c'est non je
n'ai pas d'infos personne ne nous
informe de son emploi du temps
merci c'est gentil une halte à piau on
était en droit droit nombreux plus qu'un
truc
après trois heures de recherches
infructueuses dans bel air j'ai lâché la
peur
[Musique]
les riches personnalités qui ont
participé au dîner avec donald trump
pour tenu à garder l'anonymat
sur la centaine d'invités quatre noms
sont sortis dans la presse
un seul a accepté de répondre à mes
questions
andy buzzer un business man issu de la
classe moyenne qui a fait fortune dans
le burger le pur rêve américain
et pour vendre sa viande
il joue à fond la carte sexy avec des
mannequins et des stars de la télé
réalité comme paris s'il tonne ou kim
kardashian monsieur poster un jour je
m'appelle vanina leur rencontre et
vanina merci de me recevoir
content de le faire entrer buzzer le roi
du burger a soutenu reggane
bush père puis bush fils aujourd'hui
c'est un trump heist décomplexée
le 14 juillet vous étiez bien à bel air
à la levée de fonds pour donald tusk
oui pourquoi y avez vous assisté
premièrement parce que l'organisateur de
la levée de fonds est un ami personnel
et qui m'a demandé de venir
deuxièmement parce que je voulais
entendre ce que trump avait à dire
comme vous le savez j'ai passé beaucoup
de temps à hollywood à la recherche de
républicains mais c'est très difficile
d'en trouver
la gauche a essayé de supprimer la
liberté de parole de façon agressive ce
que ce soit en politique ou ailleurs
dans le métier du cinéma on ne peut plus
parler aussi librement que l'on fait
charlton heston ronald reagan ou john
wayne dans le temps qu'ils déclaraient
qu'ils étaient républicain et donner
leur avis je ne comprends pas comment on
peut faire de la discrimination en
fonction des convictions politiques
et c'est pourtant pratiqué dans un
milieu professionnel soit disant
populaire soit disant ouvert à tous
respectueux des valeurs proches des
américains et puis on fait payer le fait
d'être républicain
c'est une honte pour notre pays et je
crois que c'est honteux pour cette
industrie
dur dur d'être républicain en californie
mais leur idéologie n'est pas totalement
absente à hollywood
quand je sillonne la ville
je constate que les films à l'affiché
sont de bon gros blockbuster jason
bourne avec matt damon
le nouveau tard dans un film de super
héros et même ben-hur un péplum biblique
du patriotisme pur jus des héros qui
seul contre tous sauve le monde des
valeurs conservatrices qui font vibrer
les américains quels sont les messages
de ses grands films hollywoodiens et
bien l'amérique est toujours le pays le
plus fort du monde toujours parlé d'une
amérique qui domine qui est puissante et
qui est d'une moralité inébranlable dans
tous les films
il est question de victoire l'amérique
est le grand vainqueur
la puissance américaine
la domination américaine à travers le
monde les politiques le répète sans
cesse notre pays est le plus fort du
monde sait que nous sommes les maîtres
du monde
c'est ce que vous entendez et ce message
est exprimée à travers tous ces films
c'est le véritable fil rouge le mythe
hollywoodien c'est toujours le héros
solitaire qui donne l'exemple
il s'en sort toujours par lui même et
vine deux héros ont toujours été une
propagande parfaite pour le parti
républicain parce que les personnages
sont des individus qui ne compte jamais
sur le gouvernement pour quoi que ce
soit finalement les messages véhiculés
par son film correspond plus aux
discours de donald forme qu'à celui
d'hillary clinton les gros blockbusters
correspondent exactement aux visions des
républicains alors hollywood
deux visages bien sûr est hypocrite
ça a toujours été comme ça ce n'est pas
parce qu'il ya des gens qui croient aux
valeurs du parti démocrate et que ces
mêmes valeurs sont exprimés dans leurs
films ces fictions sont consommés par le
grand public et le grand public
américains aiment le mythe du cowboy
on adore notre boys
[Musique]
un réalisateur symbolise toutes ses
contradictions
oliver stone wall street platoon né à 4
juillet avec tom cruise ou encore nixon
avec anthony hopkins
ces films ont marqué l'histoire du
cinéma oliver stone explore la face
sombre des grands mythes américains ses
convictions du ont parfois coûté très
cher j'avais été moins engagés
politiquement
j'aurais fait une meilleure carrière
j'aurai gagner beaucoup plus d'argent et
j'aurais fait beaucoup plus de films
parce que les studios ont refusé de
nombreux projets qui me tenait à coeur
mais pourquoi ici on se dit libre mais
en y regardant de l'autre et on n'est
pas si vide que ça flux il ya des sujets
seront ne peut pas vraiment traité
historiquement on n'aime pas la
controverse et au livret ça représente
beaucoup d'argent alors on a peur on
évite de prendre des risques
les films sont financés par des grands
groupes europe
on ne veut pas de polémique on veut
faire des films avec des héros c'est
plus facile et c'est plus accessible au
grand public
malheureusement ça appauvrit la
créativité son nouveau film raconte la
vie d'un célèbre lanceur dallaire
edouard snowdon a révélé au grand public
que les états unis espionné le monde
entier il nous donne un traître pour
washington
un film qu hollywood a donc refusé de
financer
oliver stone s'est tourné vers la france
et l'allemagne pour réaliser son long
métrage me donne a fourni les preuves
que nous sommes sur écoute pas seulement
vous et moi
mais le monde entier et l'ironie dans
tout ça c'est qu'aucun des candidats à
la présidentielle des états unis n'en
parle
cette surveillance à grande échelle ils
ne veulent pas l'évoquer c'est un gros
problème aux états unis on ne veut pas
aborder les vrais sujets on préfère se
voiler la face
monsieur 30 demande la peine de mort
pour ce lot de laits et madame clinton
demande une peine de prison très sévère
est ce le président interroge l europe
en somme en amérique on ne peut pas
réaliser des films qui serait perçu
comme contraire aux intérêts des états
unis
or pour moi ces films sont plutôt
patriotique
j'aime ce pays et je veux qu'il soit
meilleur et je crois que dire la vérité
est allé son installe c'est mieux que de
se mentir à soi-même c'est plutôt
effrayant ce que vous me dites mais bien
sur notre mur détruire
[Musique]
hollywood aux deux visages démocrates
sur les tapis rouges
lemay conservatrice dans ses scénarios
si vous aimez pas ce pays quitté le une
seule politique réconcilie acteurs et
producteurs la politique du box office
elle mesure le talent et confère
l'argent à hollywood c'est elle la vraie
puissance
[Musique]
bien
et